vous avez un pied qui est quasiment
cramer noir confie avec de l'amertume
vous avez un coeur qui est moelleux moi
je me souviens un jour de une botte
d'aspergés énorme des très très belle
aux asperges comme ça d'un diamètre mais
extraordinaire elle était ficelé en
bottes comme ça et puis il a émis deux
dans des quartiers de citron vert des
bâtonnets de citronnelle choses comme ça
et les asperges il et cuisez dans un
sautoir verticale avec un fonds de bear
comme ça et elle était simplement
arrosée au beurre pendant des heures
qu'est ce que vous avez à l'arrivée vous
avez un pied qui est quasiment cramer
noir confie avec de l'amertume
vous avez un coeur qui est moelleux et
vous avez une tête qui est presque cru
avec des sensations de verdeur inouïe
quoi et en un plat vous avez trois
moments trois émotions et ça c'est
plafond
[Musique]